so as we've been talking about
transmedia and you know this idea of
like trying to pull a bunch of stories
from our story world where do you look
to to try and craft that many stories
out of one story world like what kind of
like techniques do you use to to pull
good stories out for all these different
platforms across your story room so
people can get the theory and they can
get excited about the model but
practically what are the strategies to
use to be able to identify jumping-off
points in story that maximises the
transmedia model there's a couple ways
that I think are very easy to identify
and one of them is unanswered questions
and so I think this is the easiest way
to create transmedia opportunities is
identify unanswered questions in your
script and in a movie in a TV show
whatever it is unanswered questions and
then answer them somewhere else in a
different platform you know for example
like in you know take the the classic
example of Pulp Fiction what's in the
briefcase and if they if they didn't
answer in the film which i think was
right for the film kind of created a
mystique around the film but if if today
Tarantino launched a web series or a
comic book series or novel or something
that was all about the briefcase and the
guys to go get the briefcase and what's
in actually reveals what's in the
briefcase all of a sudden like that's a
tremendous incentive for me as a fan of
Pulp Fiction to go check that out in in
Inception where you don't know at the
end whether he's stuck in the dream or
not stuck in the dream because he spins
the top and they cut the film that's not
known as a question and so if they if
they answered that somewhere else and an
app or a song or something then that's a
transmedia opportunity I like to think
back to the Sofia Coppola first film
lost in translation at the end Bill
Murray
whispers something into her ear and you
don't know what he says and that's an
answer question and if 20 years or ten
years later however long that films been
out if they reengage the audience by you
know whether it's a love song that
reveals the line but maybe it's an email
that
Maria's character since collar
Johansson's character that the audience
is cc'd on that you get it your and
remember that time I've whispered this
into your ear in Tokyo that all of a
sudden is valuable for the audience so
if you go through a script and and you
you can readily identify transmedia
opportunities that that you may didn't
didn't know from the beginning of you
know where did that character go when
she went off screen why does he have a
black eye with what's behind that door
where does that car go what are these
guys talking about like like unanswered
questions you can probably find 15 in in
a in a existing script or pilot already
that then is then transmitted
opportunity that you can split off in
answer somewhere else or if you're
creating a writing a script from you
know square one
with this knowledge you will naturally
build in questions that you know you're
not going to answer until you release
this other thing in a different platform
and so you know a great example that is
is when in in the force awakens in Star
Wars
c-3po has a red arm and nobody knows why
c-3po has a red arm it's an unanswered
question
well then Lucasfilm released a comic
book a one-shot comic book about c-3po
and how he got the red arm it's such a
simple stupid thing that that isn't like
it's not rocket science it's like
literally play on the curiosity of
people pose a question
don't answer it answer it somewhere else
it's like ready-made transmedia in a box
JJ Abrams calls it mystery box right
he's so according this tower mystery box
of like the the human mind will always
want answers to questions and and if you
just build in intentionally questions
that you don't answer in your script
answer them somewhere else
maybe not immediately maybe wait 10
years and wait until what you feel like
your audience is starting to like wane
and die off and this is a way to
reengage them in a great way in music
you have Michael Jackson that says
Billie Jean is not my lover she's just a
girl who says that that I am the one the
kid is not my son the unanswered
question is is Michael the dad of this
kid or isn't he
he says he's not we don't know to answer
question so if today they released
something that that revealed whether
Michael was the father of that kid I
would absolutely check that out for sure
right the old day you know I'd like to
use the example of like with my my early
college days when the Baja man had that
song called who let the dogs out and
right they that if if today the Baja man
tweeted out come check out my new album
I would never click that link I can't
listen to the Baja man but if they if
they if they said hey click this link
and actually find out who let the dogs
out I would I would do that of course I
would do that and it's just a click
right and then if they pay it off by
going to the website and find an out
stoop dog let the dogs out and now
there's a new collaboration on the new
album and or whatever all of a sudden
they got me to their website but they
got me by playing on the the curiosity
of I always wonder who what the answer
to that question is so that's a great
opportunity for transmedia I think
character backstory is a great
opportunity for transmedia
we you know screenwriters deal with this
all the time how much backstory the
characters can we put in a script the
more you explore backwards the less
you're going forwards and it's always
just this push and pull in a script
because you only have a hundred and ten
pages in a feature etc etc so so if you
understand the transmedia model this is
a tremendous tool for writers to say I
can still tell my back story without
overburdening or encumbering my feature
script or my TV pilot I'm just gonna
tell the back story somewhere else in a
different platform so maybe I have my
feature script maybe I have a short
story that's the character backstory
maybe I have a song maybe I have an
animated short film that works as the
backstory over watch the video game over
watch the the video the video games the
first-person shooter and they don't tell
you any story about any of your
characters on their website they have
the backstory of all their characters
and animated short films that are
tremendous storytelling tools so they
get the backstory but they get it
without overburdening or encumbering
their video game so they basically have
their cake and they eat it too
AMC does this all the time
they'll for all the characters and all
their shows on the MC website they'll
launch launched digital comics that
explore the backstory of all their
characters which is extended content for
the fans but but for creators is great
because we'd get the things that we love
we get the backstory that we love but at
the same time we get a tight efficient
script or TV show or movie that isn't
encumbered so that's another really
super easy way different like different
parts of the story world that you can
explore if you never show what's what's
in the basement of this house then all
of a sudden a short story or a poem or a
piece of art that that shows what's in
the basement valuable comprehension
things like that there are practical
ways to approach transmedia strategy
that aren't that hard that that aren't
you know rocket scientist
type of things to figure out deleted
scenes I'm always a big fan of deleted
scenes of them not just dying on a DVD
special feature or or you know there's
always scenes that we screenwriters have
to cut out that we can't use because
we're trying to come in at page length
and so I'm always an advocate of not not
deleting but cutting and pasting and you
can take the scenes that you cut from a
script or cut from a book or a chapter
that you removed from a book or a verse
that you removed from a song and just
figuring out how to repurpose that into
into a different medium or different
platform then it's a ready-made
transmedia opportunity that's already
written then then maybe you figure out
how to how to you know turn that into an
illustrated thing or maybe maybe
communicate it through you know whatever
it is a digital platform make it a vr
opportunity or communicated through
augmented reality something like that I
think would be interesting so if you had
just imagine if you had scenes that were
cut out of Reservoir Dogs or Pulp
Fiction or something like this and then
there was a mug that you could buy that
was a Pulp Fiction mug or a Reservoir
Dogs mug that you had an augmented
reality app that you could hold up
through the mug and all of a sudden you
you you you can read or experience the
the scene that was cut out of the film
20 years earlier that's awesome
I would love that as a fan I would love
that and then and then as a fan if you
know fans would love that but why don't
do that you're wasting those scenes
anyway right so identifying that
narrative excess I'd answer questions
further story world exploration and
character backstories all great ways to
have trick like ready-made in the box
transmedia strategy
you